well very good morning to you the labour
leader sakia stama has revamped his
shadow cabinet following the
disappointing local election results
he's wielded the acts leading one former
shadow chancellor john mcdonnell
to say some of his decisions are inept
in the extreme
let's have a look at some of the details
and the biggest casualty is annelise
dodds who sacked his shadow chancellor
to become
labour party chair rachel reeves is
promoted to shadow chancellor
from the shadow chancellor of the duchy
of lancaster
deputy leader angela rayner who was
sacked as labour party chair has been
appointed the new
shadow chancellor of the duchy of
lancaster shadowing
michael gove replaces angela rainer
as national campaign coordinator
nick brown who was the chief whip has
been
replaced by alan campbell where
streeting has been promoted to
a new brief shadow child poverty
secretary
another sacking is valerie vaz who's
been removed as shadow leader of the
house of commons to be replaced by
tangum debonaire
and rumors about two of labour's highest
profile members have been scotched
lisa nandi remains as shadow foreign
secretary
and jonathan ashworth stays as shadow
health secretary
sky news spoke to former labour boat
voters in alfred
and derbyshire to get their views of
sakia's
leadership kirsten was more interested
in boris johnson's wallpaper than
real things that are happening in the
world and that's my honest opinion
labour has lost it for the working class
and there was always for the working
class people wasn't they well
i think they've really lost it
let's talk to our political
correspondent joe pike i mean it does
seem to be
a messy reshuffle yes certainly in the
last few days has been very difficult
for kierstarma not just some pretty
disappointing election results including
the by-election
in hartlepool but also over the last
couple of days we have had these
this briefing war between various
members of uh the labour top team
around in particular angela rayner's
position this is limited and not as far
as perhaps kirsten wants to go because i
think he has been weakened in past days
the key change is around the new shadow
chancellor rachel reeves is cedar to the
right of the party
therefore some on the left those around
jeremy corbyn and john mcdonnell
may be suspicious of but one person on
the left i've spoken to
in the last few minutes is actually
rachel reese whatever her politics
has been one of the most effective
shadow cabinet members the only
effective shadow cabinet member
this person said in the last few months
we'll see what she has to do
in the coming weeks okay joe thank you
well all of this comes as the prime
minister announced that the road map out
of lockdown
would be proceeding as planned with the
next season of restrictions including
the reopening of
indoor hospitality coming a week today
well let's talk to
nadine doris who's the minister for
mental health good to see you this
morning so you are confident
are you that this is not going to be any
last minute hitches in the coming week
well the prime minister will be making
an announcement later this afternoon and
he will be
uh detailing how we're going to
unlock and when but we're on the road
matt we're still very cautious
we are concerned that um that we don't
we don't release ease restrictions too
quickly and that we do this in the way
which is planned
moving forward but the prime minister
will be making announcement today so
we'll find out then well michael gove
said uh that
hugs will be allowed from a week today i
mean how important is that as a move to
be able to get physical contact
i think it's massively important to
everyone i think it's what most people
have missed that intimate
contact with family and friends and
entertaining
having people in your own house meeting
outdoors i think they've been the most
important
you know isolation in terms of my um my
own profile on mental health we've been
really concerned about you know people
being isolated
not having that usual contact with
friends and family
so it's massively important we can't
underestimate how important it is
but are there going to be problems here
in terms of
are there going to be different rules
for different ages i mean obviously a
lot of people
under 40 just haven't been vaccinated at
this stage
are they going to have to follow
different rules when it comes to social
contact and
physical contact well i'll refer you
again i'm sorry to this afternoon when
the prime minister
will be holding a press conference and
making an announcement with regard to
the next steps
of easing but you know we do have to be
cautious the last thing anybody wants is
to ever ever
be in a position that we've been in over
the last year but we are determined to
beat this virus
and and the way we can beat it is by all
of us doing what we've all done so far
which is working together to to do what
we've done over the last year
but also we you know we're looking
forward and the prime minister will be
making an announcement it does look as
though the road map
is is on course but we we do so with
caution
with ensuring that the data is in place
and
and with um with and looking forward to
and with excitement to the fact that we
will be able to
hug our family and friends soon so
caution balanced with optimism i think
is the
the way forward but but in terms of
looking at that caution then i mean
you've clearly got to
anticipate at least the possibility that
that losing that social distancing
between some people
has the potential to to create spiking
cases
so there are variants of concern in the
uk which is the reason why we are still
on the roadmap and we're still ensuring
that we
measure the data between each phase of
easement
of lockdown so you know you say you're
quite right it's
it's something we need to be really
careful about it's why we haven't just
opened up but you know we will open up
as as from next week pubs will be open
and restaurants and hospitality and
people will be able to meet
up to six people indoors in their own
homes and then we will see
how that's played out and what impact
that has on the data
and onto the on the figures and if
that's okay then you know the road map
is there it's all set out you have the
details
but the prime minister will be making an
announcement this afternoon and i would
urge everybody to watch that
announcement
but it is very important that everyone
still plays their part
and whatever is announced this afternoon
that we all do our bit
in to ensure that we absolutely
nail this virus and that we are never in
the position
again that we have been in over the last
year and we can only do that
by following the rules by playing our
part
and by doing our bit to ensure that we
beat it
and we move out of it as we are doing as
one of the most successful countries in
the world we're leading the world
in terms of coverage recovery and it's
important we keep following the plan
that we have been doing to continue on
that trajectory
is there a real danger that could be
jeopardized by i mean the reopening of
travel
obviously brings the possibility of sort
of new variants entering the uk
you are you comfortable with what has
been announced so far on that
well you know we're in a really good
position i actually saw you a few weeks
ago
uh when you were talking about travel
being used and you know
spain and wanting to get to spain and
you know we all feel that we all want to
go back on our to our summer holidays
and people want to travel and see family
abroad and go on holidays abroad
but again you know we're in a position
where we were much better we're much
better off than we were a year ago we
have search testing
we have a bilateral twice a week um
a testing natural focusing that
everybody can access now
we can uh in terms of that forget
forgive me for interrupting but in terms
of that lateral flow testing
can that can you confirm whether or not
lateral flow testing the free testing
will be available for people returning
from holidays
to prove that they're they're covered
negative is that going to be an option
rather than the
hundreds of pounds it would otherwise
cost people
i i can't and i will refer you to this
at the press conference this afternoon
um which the prime minister will be
leading
so i can't confirm that no but what i
can confirm is that easement of travel
is about ensuring that we keep variants
of concern
um under control that we can surge test
door-to-door when we need to where we
see those variants crop up
and it's about keeping people safe
absolutely
nailing this virus making sure that as a
country we can move out
cautiously and carefully so that we
never end up
where we've been again in terms of of
moving the country forward there are
lots of issues which obviously
have been pushed to the sidelines that
because of covid and understandably so
i mean i know you're you're looking at
announcing more mental health funding
for
for young people and schools at the
moment but where does
there's a huge question still remaining
around
social care in the uk and announcements
that are now way overdue
into how we begin to deal with that
well thank you for mentioning mental
health and we are making an announcement
today
17 million pounds going into schools to
help children
and to help place to fund training and
support for children to fund
mental health leads in school and that's
on top of the 2.3 billion pounds a year
we invest in mental health and
the 500 million pounds that was secured
during the spending
review so thank you for mentioning that
because children have suffered
as a result of lockdown it's really
important that they have
all the support that they need in
schools continuing
we've put eight million pounds in
september we've continued that funding
to ensure that we can spot early any
signs of
mental health problems or issues that
children have suffered as a result of
isolation and lack of access to
education
minister it's good to talk to you this
morning thank you
thank you now jerusalem has experienced
the third night of tensions with
israeli police rolling out water cannon
on some palestinian protesters let's
take you straight to our correspondent
at mark stone what's happening at the
moment mark
well you spoke to us an hour ago and
things that were calm they have turned
very very quickly a very violent series
of confrontations here
on the um just outside the al-aqsa
compound area the area of the al-aqsa
mosque let's move down here
we can show you the situation here the
israeli police are arresting people
uh as they try to clear an area an area
where
where the palestinians were praying for
their morning their morning prayer at
the end
of the daily ramadan fast we've seen
stun grenades being thrown we've seen
tear gas being fired and i could just
see the water cannon just through there
as you look out towards the mount of
olives there
uh from the lions gate here in the old
city the water cannon
are getting prepared that's a water
cannon which fires what's known as skunk
which is a rancid liquid
that takes days to yeah we'll just move
over here it takes days to
get off your skin and your clothes today
is jerusalem day
it's what israelis believe is the day
that uh
their city was unified remembering the
day the city was unified back in 1967.
clashes were always to be expected
clashes were always to be expected on
today confluence of events means that
it is extremely tense with the worst
clashes that we've seen
for quite a few years
it seems that this is a situation that
that could escalate
yeah yeah sorry to interrupt you steve
we were talking to one
man a palestinian who was in the al-aqsa
mosque a little bit earlier on
he says that the israeli soldiers were
there
and that they provoked this that they
started
attacking the protesters now i can't
tell you
if that's right because we're not
allowed into the the compound area
itself what i do know is that through
the course of the night
palestinians had stockpiled rocks in the
in the compound area because they
expected
that jewish nationalists would try
around there there's someone
injured just coming out the jewish
nationalists would try and
access the al-aqsa mosque area which the
jews
is known as temple mount their holiest
the holiest
area for judaism so it's a very very
tense situation all round
i can also say that last night when we
were at the um the damascus gate area
okay we'll move back okay
when we were at the damascus gate area
yesterday there i continue to tell you
that the
the police aggression was unprovoked the
palestinians who were gathering for the
end of
uh of their fast yesterday at the
damascus gate were simply sitting
quietly
when the police arrived with mounted uh
mounted police
and with the water cannon and began
firing into the damascus gate area that
uh i can tell you as an eyewitness was
unprovoked
the response was water bottles plastic
water bottles thrown
by some of the young palestinians um so
yeah a very very tense
day the british government um clearly
with a with a complicated history here
in this region uh has released a
statement
uh james cleverley the foreign office
minister said this morning that both
sides need to
to calm to de-escalate uh and so that
that ramadan can come to an end
uh peacefully uh there are people
stephen talking about the prospect of a
third intifada
a third palestinian uprising of course
the first two
were over a decade ago uh horrendous
bloodshed back then since then
jerusalem israel palestine has been in
somewhat
of a stalemate a stalemate that i think
has allowed the world to kind of forget
the problems that are going on here but
i think that stalemate obscures
attention that never went away
and sparks like this really reignited i
don't think we're at a stage yet where
we could talk about the prospects of a
third intifada
although some believe we are but i think
we're close
a very difficult situation the politics
is extremely complicated an entirely
dysfunctional
israeli government with benjamin
netanyahu the prime minister for well
over a decade now
trying desperately to hang on to power
and in doing so
he is trying to attract far far right
israelis
giving the far-right israeli street if
you like
a certain legitimacy to push their their
settlement
agenda into the west bank and for the
palestinians well they haven't had any
elections since 2005 in the west bank
again a politics that is um uh well uh
corrupt and uh uh letting the people
down all the time so we'll monitor
the day um but it's just gone 9 a.m
and already i've seen scores of people
injured
okay mark back to you a little bit later
on thank you
now still to come for you this morning
at half past seven i'm going to talk to
the former scottish first minister henry
mcleish
and leader of the scottish greens
patrick harvey to hear what last week's
election results mean for the future
of the union with the uk's cyber
security center revealing it took
down more scams in 2020 than the
previous three years combined we'll be
asking its chief executive
just how big a part covid themed crime
played in the search that's
at around 20 past eight and then at half
eight i'll talk to the telegraph
travel editor claire irvin and the
founder of trail finders mike gooly
as travel firms begin taking bookings
for some
summer holidays
now of course it's not a site you'd
expect to see in a river running through
a city but last night a dramatic rescue
operation kicked off after a baby
minky whale got stuck in the thames it's
now been set free
anisha sethi reports and a warning this
does show
some footage of the whale in distress
it looks like
it still remains a mystery how this baby
minky whale became stuck in the thames
in south west london but passersby in
richmond
believed they were among the first to
see it trapped in the log
when they raised the alarm at 6 pm on
sunday evening
we called in the port of london
authority
eventually we got up here we saw him
being stuck again we called
the port of london authority again the
guys from the lock
came by to water him down nobody
no one was allowed to touch him or
anything like that so we're
not able to do anything or help in any
way and now we're back just to see
just to check what we were hoping not to
see anyone at all
as the evening drew in it became a
combined effort to float the whale
and maneuver it to safety a team of
water rescue firefighters
and marine specialists tried to shift
the mammal onto inflatable pontoon
crafts
but there were several failed rescue
attempts
throughout the mission the wales welfare
was a prime
concern for the teams trying to help it
to safety
she's not he or she we're not sure isn't
nicely rounded like a healthy whale
would be
so possibly nutritionally compromised
there's also
um some damage to the pectoral fins from
stranding and also
the skin is showing signs that perhaps
it was stranded earlier in the day
somewhere as well
um it's in fairly poor condition but now
it's quite comfortable
the breathing rate's nice and low
[Music]
in the early hours of monday morning
crowds cheered
as the whale was eventually moved by
authorities
the whale was taken from a non-tidal
lock area to
a stable area where they would then take
further assessments on what is best for
the whale
and moving forward in weaver to take it
out to sea or to work on it further
and the best interest for the whale
itself vets will now continue to assess
the creature's condition
to determine whether it's healthy enough
to be released
anisha sethi sky news
well let's talk to emma birchley who's
in richmond for us this morning what's
the latest emma
well it was in the early hours of the
morning that the whale
was finally moved from here and it was
put inside that um
inflatable flotation device it was like
an inflatable pontoon not dissimilar to
a stretcher and the idea was that
when it was towed away by the port of
london authority patrol boat and
chiswick lifeboat
that had actually be taken downstream
and then assessed further but actually
what happened is that
about a mile away in the isle worth area
the whale slipped from that inflatable
flotation device
and swam away into the darkness now it
was expected that that may well
happen so now the whale is in the river
um hopefully heading as the tide
goes out towards the sea but the fact is
it's many many miles from the sea
and as we know this is a whale that was
not in a good condition that
a young animal uh quite underweight
also with damage to his pectoral fins
so it's now really up to the public to
be able to keep their eyes out and boats
on the river
to see if they can spot this whale
in the hope that it does manage to make
it out to sea but the fact is
is that these whales are usually found
in the northern parts of the north sea
so we're talking about
the more northernmost parts of the uk
it's definitely very lost and
you know it doesn't necessarily look
good at this stage but everyone as i
said being urged to keep their eyes out
okay emma thank you
well let's have a look at some of the
other headlines making the news this
morning
and travel disruption is expected to
continue
into the week after some high-speed
trains were found to have cracks
in the maintenance section the makers of
the hitachi
800 say it discovered cracks in the
fleet at a very early stage
great western advised against travel
while lner
urged people with bookings to check
before they traveled
disruption to heart disease care caused
by the pandemic could be putting lives
at risk for
years to come that's a warning from the
british heart foundation
which predicts a sharp rise in the
number of people who've died from hard
and circulated circulatory diseases
in 2020 the amount of time people are
waiting for procedures has really
changed
from a few dozen by the end of february
2020
to 5 000 people waiting over a year
for heart procedures including surgery
at the end of february this year
that's heart surgery heart surgery is
not a luxury
so these are really stark figures um
showing the disruption in care
so david attenborough has warned the
world faces crippling problems because
of climate change
the broadcast has been given the role of
people's advocate ahead of this year's
cop
26 summit in glasgow which will bring
together
global leaders to tackle the issue
the problems that await us within the
next five to ten years
are even greater it is crucial
that these meetings in glasgow cop
26 have success and that at last
the nations will come together to solve
the crippling problems that the world
the globe now faces
royal mail is trialling the use of
drones to deliver covid19 testing kits
and other health and safety equipment to
the isles of silly from mainland uk
if it succeeds the technology could be
rolled out across the country
to support postal workers in delivering
to remote areas
now the sound of leather hitting a
willow cricket bat
is a quintessential sound of british
summer but researchers say that bats
made of bamboo
could be the future a study carried out
by the university of cambridge
discovered the bamboo version offered a
larger sweet spot
than the traditional willow blade and is
stronger
cheaper and more sustainable
who do you now i don't think it's going
to be crooked weather today let's get
all the details from nas morning
good morning yeah i mean there will be a
bit of wet weather around to say the
least
in the way of showers and that means
there will be interruption to play if
there's any cricket
being played today
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning low pressure dominates the
scene for this week so again it's
staying unsettled
by the way of showers for most places
today but there's also some rather heavy
rain in fact this morning
there are spells of rain across eastern
parts of england there's been some heavy
downpours particularly around parts of
kent there's been around 20 millimeters
through the night
and that rain will be eventually moving
its way northwards elsewhere we're
seeing showers across northern and
western parts otherwise it's actually a
mainly dry and fine start to the day
and a frost-free morning the first
frost-free morning in
over a month since the end of march now
going into this afternoon that heavy
rain will be moving its way northwards
across the north sea and up towards
parts of shetland and orkney where it's
going to be a pretty wet one there
as we continue with heavy downpours
across the northern isles of scotland
perhaps for the far northeast of maine
and scotland
elsewhere across the uk and ireland
showers will become more widespread and
some of these
are going to be quite heavy and thundery
may even merge into longer spells of
rain at times
and with the showers there will be some
rather strong
gusty winds particularly around western
exposed coasts but as you can see
towards the end of today
for many central southern and eastern
parts of wales and england
the showers will tend to disappear so
actually from around mid-afternoon
onwards
it's looking fine for many areas outside
but further north and west quite
blustery
with showers continuing across these
areas and temperatures around average or
just a little below
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nas thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast i'm going to talk to a former
scottish first minister
and the leader of the scottish greece to
hear about the growing pressure
on the union
there are things we all take for granted
as the rivers and tides flow
the sun will rise the wind will blow
and the earth will spin but are we now
spiraling into a climate crisis
which cannot be avoided no one can
predict the impact that it's going to
have
close to the peak here this is really
the moment of truth
expected to be hit very hard indeed what
can be done
to reverse the spiral the daily climate
show on sky news will look for the
answers
lots of people have discovered during
lockdown they really
got onto the hobby of house plants and
so
sales of house plants have been going
surging
and everyone's been sharing lots of
pictures of plants on their social media
and getting very excited about plants
that perhaps a few years ago nobody was
really that bothered about
i i think it's a really serious issue
that every part of horticulture
needs to be engaged with you don't need
to grow
house plants in pete i grow all my house
plants
in peat-free potting mix it's not
necessary
but unfortunately lots of the plants
that we buy are still grown
in peat so it's a question of educating
yourself about why pete
is not a good thing to use as a as a
medium for house plants
from an environmental point of view and
looking at the
excuse me looking at the alternatives
and there are there are lots of
alternatives
so but sustainability is wider than that
as well
it extends to things like learning to
propagate your own house plants so you
can
swap with friends growing houseplants
from seed
buying pots from charity shops rather
than buying new pots
cutting down on plastic by using
terracotta so there's lots of different
ways that you can
make your houseplant hobby sustainable
lots of plants
have very different requirements so a
cactus is not going to be happy in the
same spot
as a fern so do your research pick your
plant to suit the conditions that you've
got in your house
and take care of it and observe it every
day
don't stick it on a high shelf and
ignore it because you won't notice when
things start to go wrong
the main benefit of houseplants is just
being able to see the greenery
and nurture it and that does bring about
great
mental health benefits
now the head of a private hospital in
india's most popular state has been
charged under the national security act
for raising the alarm about the oxygen
shortage there
it's the latest attempt by authorities
to clamp down on what they call
black marketing spreading rumors and
spoiling the atmosphere
well in the latest 24-hour period india
has recorded
over 403 738 new cases of coronavirus
bringing the total number of cases to
nearly 22.3 million
4092 new deaths were recorded on
saturday
that brings the total number of deaths
over the course of the pandemic
to more than 242 thousand
well maharashtra state which includes
mumbai has
india's highest number of deaths so far
with over 75 000 recorded
delhi is the second worst affected
region with 9
19 000 recorded cases utah pradesh
india's most popular state
with 200 million people has also been
badly affected
with more than 15 000 deaths but as our
special correspondent alex crawford
reports
that number is likely an undercount
they're fighting on several fronts in
india
fighting to save lives but also fighting
to tell it as it is
and those at this hospital in lucknow
are now facing police charges for doing
just that
every covert patient who arrives here
desperately needs oxygen
but those who sounded the alarm about
oxygen shortages at this hospital
are now being charged under the national
security act
and face being arrested at any moment
[Music]
the head of this small hospital says
four of his patients died in one day
when
oxygen ran out he showed me the messages
he put out
desperately asking for help
when he got no response he put out a
notice telling relatives they should
take the patients elsewhere
a number of them did but others had no
choice
the hospital head took us to see his
small oxygen store
it's again at dangerously low levels the
state's high court has said not
supplying oxygen to hospitals
is a criminal act no less than genocide
foreign
but the oxygen ran out by nine o'clock
that morning
the relatives of those who died say
that's what killed them
if the oxygen had been there my aunt and
cousin would not have died he told us
as we traveled through uttar pradesh
with its huge population of 200 million
we found many ignoring covert warnings
this is meant to be locked down still
bustling with people
and few masks
in the shadow of india's most famous
monument they appeared
oblivious to the virus
doctors we've spoken to say the mutation
which has spread to other countries
including britain
is a far more aggressive infectious
variant
and affecting far younger people it
seems that the virus is more lethal this
time
it seems so because the number of deaths
have been a little higher than what was
what we saw last time also what we are
observing is
last year it took some time for the
patient to deteriorate
but with this virus the infectivity or
the
aggressiveness of the virus is so high
that it hardly takes a day
for the patient otherwise fine to
desaturate and
get compromised
there's a fear about contradicting the
official numbers
but this crematorium in agra has run out
of wood
and is now using cow dung for its
funeral pies
nearly two-thirds of indians live in
remote
rural areas unable to get any help for
covid
with many dying at home and untested
the workers have no protective outfits
against the virus
whilst telling us they've never been so
busy but they're reluctant to give exact
figures
why don't you just tell them the young
boy behind him says
he gets a furious response
in these areas of such deprivation where
religious sadhus are often the only
people recognizing the dead
we may never know the real toll of the
pandemic in india
alex crawford sky news in uttar pradesh
now after the scottish national party
won 64 seats one short of an overall
majority in a fourth
consecutive hollywood election first
minister nicolas sturgeon has vowed to
press ahead with plans
for a second independence referendum
putting further pressure
on the state of the union boris johnson
says
another vote would be irresponsible miss
surgeon said
blocking any plans would be picking a
fight
with the scottish people well let's talk
to
former first minister henry mccleesh
good to see you this morning do you
agree with
with nicolas sturgeon that if if
westminster says no this is picking a
fight
well that may not be necessary to ask
that particular question because
what i'm encouraged by is that over the
weekend you know weekend
has changed some attitude so now we're
beginning to focus on the union
because there's no doubt the snp did
remarkably well we're heading towards 20
years in government
but scotland is still a very divided
country as far as the constitutional
questions concern
so this morning we're talking now about
what the union has to do
to retain um scotland's membership
offered
i think that's encouraging and that's
how the debate i think will pursue
i'm slightly confused because it's one
thing to push an argument for
for for the union to continue but i mean
one ultimate way to settle that is that
is the referendum question
i mean do you not think there is a
legitimacy in nicola sturgeon calling
for that referendum again
i think there is a legitimacy i think
there is also legitimacy in the fact
that scott should decide
now let's step back there isn't going to
be a referendum for some time
but there will be a referendum in the
future but i think it's important to
recognize
that one of the reasons why independence
has done so well as a policy
is because it's been uncontested the
union has sat idly by
complacently by and of course boris
johnson has become
really more of an aggravation in the
whole debate than anything else
so this is an opportunity not to deny a
referendum that will happen
of course the pandemic recovery climate
change will intervene before then
but on the other hand the encouraging
point this morning is that for the first
time
independence may get a run for its money
that hasn't happened before
and i think it's important when scots
make any final decision
they know what a new union could look
like a new constitutional settlement
could look like
and a union which is not being um bashed
around
by boris johnson but actually is
sympathetic to the ideas of four nations
i mean why do you think boris johnson is
is bashing it about and not giving the
union a new vision
well there is a view in scotland that
boris johnson may be popular in england
but he's certainly not a serious player
in scotland and up to now we've seen the
single market which is trying to hijack
policies that were coming back from
europe to scotland
now to be dealt with in london we've
seen the threat of taking scotland to
court the scottish government to
the supreme court over the question of
putting children's rights
into the european court into their own
scottish legislation we've seen this
kind of muscular unionism from johnson
either he doesn't understand at what
he's doing or if he does understand
it's a very dangerous path to take so my
ingredients for a debate are
that he withdraws from this very hostile
position in relation to scotland
we start to talk about what a new
settlement might look like
to to retain scottish membership and we
also then have to
recognize and respect that half of
scotland's electorate voted for the snp
and whilst johnson may try and
delegitimize the snp
he can't delegitimize the people of
scotland and half of the electorate
so i think the since the weekend i think
we're beginning to see
some light being shed on the very murky
views that westminster is taking
off scotland and scotland's role in the
union
and yet i mean yeah murky they may be i
mean that's not for dispute but i mean
you're
you're the man who said that the
scottish parliament itself was
was full of hate on this issue
well look i think you've hit an
important subject not the hate issue but
the problem
i believe that the parliament is in its
infancy 22 years old
what we need is a bigger better stronger
more ambitious parliament
and we can get that and that'll be one
of the ways for the union to move
forward
and you're absolutely right to say in
this maturing process that is still far
too much hatred
especially between labour and of course
the snp
we've got to grow forward as well as
move forward and i believe sincerely
that the parliament has a lot more to
offer in the decades that lie ahead
but in the meantime the parliament
should be the focus upon which
all the parties in scotland and the
scottish people can
come to an agreement on what they want
to do next and deliver it to westminster
and i would like to think that
westminster will respond but look
be in no doubt there's a powerful voice
for independence at the present time
if that is not retreated carefully then
it could emerge to the point
where we have a referendum there will be
a vote for scotland to exit the union
this is the nature of the debate so i
think we should look at the
you know the calls that are being made
by some people which are extreme
but on the other hand there is a big big
debate not only affecting scotland's
future
but the future of the united kingdom
henry clayton good to talk to you this
morning thank you
well let's talk to patrick harvey who's
the co-leader
of the scottish green party good to see
you this morning can i ask what what you
make of henry mcleish's comments because
i mean clearly a union is clearly
wanting to maintain the union but but
not dismissing the idea of a referendum
far from it
well good morning thanks for having me
on i think where
henry is right and obviously he and i
would have a
disagreement is that the uk position
needs not only a legal technicality to
rely on
it needs political legitimacy and that
fundamentally can only flow
from respecting the the democratically
expressed wishes
of the people of scotland they may
choose to go to court ultimately to say
the scottish parliament
may not do this and that the scottish
people may not even be allowed to be
asked the question but
i think if they do that it will lack so
much political legitimacy
lacks so much respect for democracy that
it will push more and more people
into supporting independence personally
i think independence is coming
i think it's going to be achieved
through a referendum in the not too
distant future
and i think it's going to allow the
people of scotland to decide for
themselves
what kind of country is going to emerge
from coven whether we're going to be the
fairer
more equal and greener society that i
think most of us want to be
or if we're going to be part of boris
johnson's brexit britain
but that decision must lie with the
people of scotland
not with the man behind the door of
number 10 down in the street there's a
danger isn't there in in talking about
being part of boris johnson's britain i
mean boris
because this this is about we're talking
decades
in the future here i mean you know this
is this is about being part of
of the union as a whole i mean henry
mcleish saying
that that arguments need to be made to
establish
why better establish why the union is a
good thing we
do you think the people of scotland
people like yourself even are willing to
listen to those arguments if
if if new thoughts come forward
well yeah i mean you're right that it's
not all about boris johnson he's in
office today and he's the one making
this decision today and i think he
should respect the
wishes of the people of scotland but he
may not be in office long he certainly
won't be there forever
but you know scotland can make one of
two choices it can be part of
of brexit britain uh whoever sent
government of the day
uh despite the fact that the
overwhelming majority of people in
scotland voted to stay in the eu
or it can be an independent country
looking to see if we can get back into
the family of european nations
those two main paths uh are not going to
give us the same prospects
for recovery for transition away from
the fossil fuel industry
and for all of the other changes that
are required in our society i believe
that independence offers that that
better path but what's been striking
about this election campaign is that
those
who want scotland to stay in the uk
those who oppose independence
have overwhelmingly focused on the
process issue
why you shouldn't have a referendum now
you know what would be a mandate
never mind the fact that they ignored
the fact that the conservatives never
had a majority of
uh of people's votes to give them a
mandate to hold the brexit referendum in
the first place
but they they focus on those process
questions i don't hear
any of them genuinely making a case for
saying
that the uk as it stands is is working
for scotland and that it's the best path
for scotland
uh despite the fact that we have nuclear
weapons in
scottish waters that we don't want we
have the home office conducting dawn
raids against asylum seekers in glasgow
we have a whole host of uh impacts from
the social security system which cause
poverty and inequality
and we have huge amounts of money being
spent on fossil fuel
tax breaks and subsidies propping up a
lethal industry that's ripping apart
ripping apart
our life support system so yeah i think
there's a there's a huge appetite for
change in scotland
and there is a a real limit on the
amount of change that we can achieve uh
if we don't
take the next step from devolution to
independence
patrick harvey it's good to talk to you
this morning can i just uh i fully
approve your patrick trout
image as well on the wall very nice
thank you very much
very nice i'll still come on sky news
breakfast
i'm going to be talking to special envoy
to the world health organization on the
risks of allowing
foreign travel
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
most places will have sunny spells and
showers today some of them will be
locally heavy
with the risk of thunder and hail there
will also be rain over eastern parts of
england that will move northwards to
shetland and orkney with heavy downpours
it'll be breezy for many areas too
especially around coastal counties and
any showers
pollen levels will be generally high
across many central southern and eastern
parts of
england for today where there will be
the driest and sunniest conditions
elsewhere will have moderate levels
except across the north of scotland
where it'll be most unsettled and their
levels will be
low the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
now some international travel will
resume from next monday as the
government names 12 countries that it
deems
safe to travel to but as travel begins
to restart
scientists are warning that new variants
pose a real risk
and that we are at a fearsome stage of
the pandemic well
that particular phrase of being fearsome
was used by dr
david nabarro special envoy on kovid19
for the world health organization he
joins us now it's good to see you
as always i mean how concerned are you
about international travel
opening up in the way that we intend to
do it in the uk
well i i've been impressed by the care
with which
as far as i can see the british
government is trying to work out
which are the safe places to go to and
secondly i'm also
pleased with the the reality that people
are being
quite cautious as you say perhaps even a
little bit afraid
of what this virus might bring and and i
think that the
fear part is important but we need to
keep it in perspective
the fear is because the virus is
changing it's mutating all the time and
we know that new variants are emerging
and that these are capable of being
transmitted more easily
but i think at the same time we've got
to get on with life
and we can't go on mothballing ourselves
forever
so finding a way to restart despite this
fear is what i think we'll have to do
and just to
therefore give you my summary we must
maintain a very vigilant
posture in the coming months because
there
will no doubt be variants appearing
but at the same time we have to get on
with life
so in our getting on with life we have
to just be on the lookout for new spikes
of disease
and deal with them when they come is
there an issue that i mean obviously
we've done very well with the
vaccinations
in the uk does it give a perhaps a false
sense of security when it comes to the
new variants
yes there is no security with this virus
it is constantly capable of changing
and as it changes it has the ability
we believe and not not not demonstrated
so far
but it could develop the ability to be
able to evade
the protection that's been given to us
by these wonderful vaccines
but we do without when it comes and we
deal with it
by being on the alert and by being able
to pick up
uh new clusters of disease very very
fast
and then to deal with them also very
fast
and that will be the posture for the
future being on the defensive
being able to do with it whether it's a
new variant
or the original virus it's the same
method
find it make sure people are isolated
and find their contacts and isolate them
that's the
basis of dealing with this particular
virus i mean we
we we have a warped sense of of of
covid19
don't we when we we look at a country
like the uk
beginning to open up whilst on the other
hand you know i think you're quoted as
saying
you know infections are accelerating
faster than ever
on a global level can we ever i mean
it's a case of how do we then begin to
tackle the global issue to bring about a
a certain level of global security on
this
well and and that's of course where i
concentrate
virtually all my efforts because we have
a a fairly unpleasant situation in south
asia at the moment
and many of you will have seen really
distressing pictures and you will have
had messages
from people in not just india but
neighbouring countries and they would
tell you
just how difficult it is but you know
stephen that
acute upsurge in numbers of cases could
happen
anywhere and that's what i think we're
all beginning to realize
and so on the one hand we've got a
dangerous virus
on the other hand we must get on with
life because
it just can't go on with the
restrictions that people have had
up till now and finding that middle path
how to live with this virus as constant
threat is key
i suppose that brings me back to your
earlier question
if i really were able to talk to
everybody
personally over the coming weeks i would
say
look yes you you must restart life and
and
everybody wants you to do that but
please be
really careful maintain that physical
distance of between one meter and two
meters
especially indoors and don't forget to
wear your face mask because that
really can give extra protection it's
these simple things but all done
together
that will really make the difference as
to whether or not
future spikes are huge or future spikes
are small
and easily contained david always good
to talk to you thank you
thank you very much for the time when
all the papers are full of being able to
hug
next monday the experts saying still
keep your distance
where you can interesting advice isn't
it okay let's have a look at the weather
for you with nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning low pressure dominates the
scene so once again we are looking at
unsettled conditions for today sunshine
and showers good news this morning
though it's the first frost-free start
of the day since
over a month since the end of march and
it is looking fine across many central
southern and eastern areas although
eastern parts of england are
experiencing some spells of heavy rain
that will move northwards
up towards shetland and orkney later
elsewhere showers across the north and
west becoming more widespread this
afternoon
some of them heavy and thundery but from
about mid-afternoon dry conditions for
central southern and eastern parts of
wales and england
the weather sponsored by qatar airways